[Music]
my name is Alicia Sal Maroni and I lead
strategic partnerships at Google for
education today you're gonna hear from
students and researchers who are using
GCP to discover black holes in the
universe new painkillers that could help
us address the opioid crisis as well as
communication devices that can enable
the deaf
joining me today are Elana and Tomer
from Columbia University vite Kuhn from
Stanford slack and Neal from the
university of southern california you'll
hear their stories in just a moment this
quote from Ryan Abernathy a climate
researcher at Columbia University really
says it all for me
the amount of data in academic as well
as scientific research is exploding and
researchers really have no option but to
look to the cloud but what the cloud is
enabling them to do is to make
discoveries faster Ryan used GCP in his
lab and he made no does he's able to ask
more questions different questions take
a moment to read that last line really
hits home doesn't it we have two
programs that enable students and
researchers to get started on GCP at no
cost the first is the education faculty
Grants Program this program provides
free credits to faculty who want to use
GCP in their courses with their students
courses from computer science to
engineering as well as business
operations and anything revolving data
science are already leveraging GCP
credits apologies our second program is
the GCP research credits program
researchers can apply for free credits
and they can use this in their lab for
any type of evaluation experimentation
or testing we have researchers
sequencing genomes
learning and researching about
life-forms in the galaxies far away and
as well as far deep underneath not
underneath the ocean floor but near the
ocean floor so with that I would love to
introduce our first presentation from
Tomer Nolan at Columbia University
imagine not being able to call your
loved ones imagine not being able to
call nine-one-one during an emergency
imagine someone was listening to every
single phone call you made you don't
have to imagine 30 7.5 million adults in
the u.s. report suffering from some sort
of hearing loss that's 15 percent of the
u.s. population what do these people do
how do they place phone calls well today
people with hearing disabilities have to
use a captioning service what that means
is if I want to call a friend who's hard
of hearing I'm being transferred to a
man-in-the-middle that's an actual human
being
listening to everything I say type it
and send it to a special device that the
other side must own think about it for a
second it can take almost a minute from
the moment I say something to the time
the other side here is it this is crazy
let's don't even talk about privacy
someone is listening to everything I say
dear is 2019 we have self-driving cars
we created rockets that can go out to
space and land back on earth and still
if you have trouble hearing if you're
hard of speaking
there is no way for you to make a decent
phone call we want to change that that's
why we created Nagesh Nagesh stands for
accessible in Hebrew and our mission is
to make phone calls more accessible how
we do that to explain I'd like to call
my partner alone Ezra to the stage all
right so I want to go back to the
captioning service
Tomer just mentioned and tell you a
short story that happened to me so I
wanted to contact Jack from the New York
deaf Association to talk about
collaboration and offer him beta testing
for free and just hear his opinion but I
was connected to a captioning service
and that was a little bit strange for me
because that was the first time I really
encountered that and by the end of the
conversation even became more awkward I
was telling Jack about this new service
that Omar just introduced they will take
away the work from the captioning
service and I had to do it through the
captioning service so I didn't it didn't
feel right and I felt like there's no
privacy and I can't even imagine how
Jack feels every single day so now
that's why we created Nagesh we want to
bring privacy and independence back to
phone calls so Jack can be just on the
go users phone whenever he wants
so how would that conversation look like
today using a nagesh instead of
captioning service in a man in the
middle that transcribed everything I say
back and forth and it's slow tedious
process we just used Google
speech-to-text API which basically takes
my voice my sound and converts it into
text that text we send to Jack mobile
phones and now he can just read what I
said
simple enough now if Jack wants to
respond back he can use Google Hangouts
Facebook Messenger
what's up telegram and many more that
we're planning to support in future and
just respond tie back send a message
when he sends the message we converted
back to speech to voice
and we send it to my phone and I hear
exactly what Jack type and now we're
both happy again and we have a normal
phone call like any other person in the
world and simple as that if this is cool
the coolest part is we were able to
build it in less than 12 hours we
started in a coding competition in our
school Columbia University and with
Google products we were able to have a
working demo by the end of the day and
to show you how many Gish works here's a
video me gustaría Reservoir una Mesa
parados a las ocho de la noche
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey I just got you okay I'll be there in
a second
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so as you can see we're pretty
excited by this but the question that we
must ask is where can we go next so
we're currently working with beta
testers to test our service improve it
and make it really something that they
can use every single day besides that we
have conference calls that we want to
make them more we want to make you want
to use an occasion a more professional
way so they can use it while they work
yeah also we wanted to create
personalized voices so for instance
adults won't have the same voice as
child we feel like that each person
should have the unique voice even if
they can't speak if you want to hear
more about negation read about what
we're doing check out our website at
talk nagesh Co where you'd also find a
live transcript of this keynote that was
generated using the same technology that
empowers nagesh and if you all like to
see a live demo please find us at the
Guru for education booth right after
this talk and we're gonna be there until
the end of the day hope to see you and
now Mike kun is coming to stay to speak
about space thank you thanks guys
before I begin I just have a question
did any of you get a chance to check out
the latest news today about the
first-ever photo of black hole it just
came out this morning right right so uh
yeah I'm gonna be talking about similar
things here hopefully I guess you
excited so hi everyone my name is Mike
Koontz and I'm a researcher at Stanford
at SLAC National Lab just down the road
from here I'd like to talk to you about
unlocking a vast trove of data to study
the secrets of the universe cool things
like dark matter and dark energy
ninety-six percent this might surprise
you but we don't know
96% of what's out there in the universe
everything you see in that photo tens of
thousands of galaxies our own galaxy our
tables our chairs you and me every
single thing only comprises 4% of the
matter in the universe that's a lot we
don't know what's out there 96 percent
is what we need to find out so to unlock
the secrets of that 96% we're gonna need
a lot of information the universe just
by virtue of existing provides us for
this information all around us we need a
way to collect that information and then
study it to be able to study what's
going on this is where I come in my job
as a researcher is to create a system
that is able to collect all this
information and provide a platform for
astrophysicists and astronomers and any
scientist who's interested to study the
data and look into the secrets of the
universe I'm to Google we've also been
able to create a platform that helps us
do that for the data management system
we're gonna need a telescope to power
the images that give us all that data
this is where LSST comes in it's called
a large synoptic survey telescope this
telescope will provide the deepest
widest image of the University date it's
gonna be the world's biggest camera
based telescope every single picture
that you see online even the one that
came out today it comes from
collaborating with a bunch of other
telescopes taking lots and lots of
exposures tons of analysis done on them
lots of algorithms that eventually gives
you a nice pretty picture that you can
look at now how would we do that for
hundreds or thousands and in the end
millions of pictures we're gonna need a
really huge machine this is where LSST
comes in it's a project being built in
Chile right now and the next video will
show you since the scale of what this
telescope is about
[Music]
[Music]
all right so yeah that should give you
an idea of what's going on it's it takes
hundreds of people stands as a scientist
to make this thing and it's been
envisions you know over ten years ago
and finally got funding in like 2010 and
it's been under construction since it's
gonna be in production in about 20 21 22
and provide us with all these images
that we can look at so how big is this
telescope exactly the camera behind this
telescope is 3200 megapixels just think
of your cell phone they are the best
ones are usually 10 to 12 megapixels and
take pretty nice photos every single
exposure with this telescope is 3200
megapixels that's about the size of 40
full moons one image it takes one of
these images every 15 seconds and it's
gonna do that over 10 years from 2021 to
2030 ish that ends up being 15 terabytes
of data per night and in the end 37
billion stars and galaxies for us to
look at it's a lot of information in
that database in the end so with all
these hundreds of scientists thousands
of people that wanna they're interested
in this data that want to discover new
things from this survey of the sky we're
gonna need a data management platform
that can easily enable them to do that
so currently LSST is based in Chile and
with scientists for collaborating with
scientists in the u.s. imagine there's a
scientists in Australia who's also
interested in studying dark matter and
dark energy via their own telescope or
their own collaboration and they've
never had anything to do with all sisty
before they have information about twee
cleansing for example which is one way
to study a dark matter and dark energy
one of the ways that scientists make
progress on measurements and equations
is to combine measurements and iterate
on current current accepted values they
can bring their own data spin up
everything that we provided in Google
Cloud with our data management system
with our services with our data compare
it against what they have at their own
costs which enables them to combine into
a new measurement for dark matter and
dark matter and dark energy
cost is of course a part of any equation
on campus because that that's really
important when it comes to researchers
because we always rely on government
funding this brings us to the proof of
concept that else is t worked with with
Google this was practically an exercise
in running our data managed system that
has been planned for operation of the
telescope and running it in the cloud
this means we took our database system
our associative services things that we
containerized and kubernetes sized made
it made it easy available and deployable
by others and not just experts and run
them on GCP the way we compare
performance was by benchmarking things
that we've already done on our own data
centers and with things called kpms or
key performance metrics this was this is
an ongoing study I cannot really talk
too much about the numbers but in
certain cases in certain classes of
queries that scientists like to run we
saw improvements of up to 10x in times
that it takes to get results out of
queries one of the things that I do want
to mention throughout our proof of
concept is that the Google professional
services people were really helpful in
hands-on in helping us bring our entire
DNA management system onto the cloud
which really made things easy and in the
end that is our objective to create a
system that's easy flexible to use even
other scientists and non experts should
be able to use as well so for other
researchers thinking about getting on
the cloud I want to talk about a special
point which is every researcher every
type of research not just astronomy not
just biology and not just literally
everything has special requirements
because there's very specific ways to do
things and that's that's really it's
really bespoke to the type of analysis
that you're doing it's sometimes
difficult to think that it would be
possible to do that somewhere else and
not just your own system your own data
center your own specialized system that
you've created but I wanted to talk
about how we were able to do that still
at GCP for example one of the things
that we've done in our system is
something called shared scans
and what that does is when you submit a
query that looks at the entire data
which is a very frequent thing that
scientists like to do any further query
that comes into the system tags lawn and
it adds no further overhead to the
system and that way we can look at the
entire data set for one query or a
hundred queries and it should work
exactly the same another specific thing
that astronomers need for LSST is
something called spherical geometry
think of what think about Google Maps
for a second when you kind of scroll out
you see that the coordinates are in a
sphere right you zoom out and you look
at distances between two points it's
actually a curve in the same way when
we're taking photos of the night sky and
all these images if you think about it
we're in the center of that globe so we
need an accurate way to look for objects
around other objects distances between
things accurately with that with
spherical geometry in mind so we can
calculate those things accurately things
like that we're also adaptable in things
like bigquery where we could make
special UDF's and other functions to be
able to do that in the way that we need
so I can go on and on about all the
specific things that we did and tried
but if you're interested more about the
SSD data management team you can find
out more in that link and ultimately
what I want to say is that our objective
is to build a system that is really easy
to use flexible for other scientists for
other non experts and really enable
science output out of this experiment
for as many papers as possible and have
the Heather scientists concentrate more
on delivering science results rather
than worrying about the underlying
technology because after all we still
have a 96% of the universe left to
understand with that I will hand over to
the next speaker Neel who would like to
talk about the opioid crisis
[Applause]
Thank You a coned hi everyone my name is
Nils and patil and I am a graduate
student at the University of Southern
California and today I'm going to share
a story about fight against the opioid
epidemic in the Google cloud what we are
trying to do here is to design better
drug better painkillers faster
what takes more than a year in a normal
research lab takes less than a day on
Google Cloud opioid epidemic so the u.s.
is currently facing a true national
emergency as opioid epidemic and more
than hundred and thirty people every day
or close to 50 thousand people every
year die because of opioid epidemic to
put this in perspective this number is
even higher than people dying from car
accidents in fact in the next ten
minutes while I do this talk one person
will die because of opioids in the US so
let's look at where this started the use
of opiates dates back to even centuries
and it's social and cultural impacts can
still be found in early civilizations
including Romans and Egyptians back then
it was all there from natural products
it was there from poppies but now as you
can see here it has gone totally
synthetic it has been much more powerful
and much more addictive back then it had
impacted human history and wars were
fought because of opioids one such
example is the first opium war which was
fought between British backed East India
Company and the Chinese kingdom back
then we only had morphine which was
sterile from poppy but with even more
powerful synthetic opioids nowadays the
challenges become even more grave and
take a look at the map of the US and see
how it's impacting the u.s. at the early
level of income culture and race
take a moment and find the region you
belong to and see how severely it's
impacted by the opioid epidemic so let
me switch your gears and see how this
works in terms of biology so in layman's
term you can think of these operate
drugs as keys keys which binds to a set
of proteins in our brain called the
opioid receptors so human body is made
up of cells and cells help cell walls
and gülfem them and the cell membranes
have these gatekeepers or these open
receptors sitting across the membrane
and when these keys or external
molecules bind to these receptors either
they activate them or they block them
and when it comes to pain management in
the brain there are two major pathways
one pathway leads to pain relief which
is the desired effect but activating
another pathway leads to undesired side
effects such as respiratory depression
and tolerance so whether drug will
activate one pathway or another or it
will block the receptor it depends on
the structure of these keys or the drugs
and how they interact with these
receptors so you don't really have a
choice as to whether you want to get
addicted or not it's not in our hands
it's up to these receptors and how they
function in our brains
so here isn't short visualization it's
actually a molecular dynamic simulation
showing an opioid drug binding to an
opioid receptor so in purple this drug
and the blue spirals is the opéra
receptor so our answer to fight this
challenge of opioid epidemic is with
design and find better create keys keys
that point these receptors and our lab
has been working on these targets since
more than a decade so here is what we
are going to do to fight fight this we
and our colleagues have solved the
atomic level 3d structures of the
receptors or this locks and once you
know how this locks work then you can
design and screen better keys so once we
have the description or
three-dimensional description of these
receptors then we throw in bunch of keys
or small drug like molecules and find
those ones which can interact with these
these these locks and show desired
effect so here is where the action
happens actually so in this video what
it may look like bunch of the things
happening what is actually showing is we
are screening different keys and this
process is called virtual again
screening in this process we evaluate a
single drug molecule in different of
blocking poses and we calculate
different chemical interactions for them
and in this process there thousands of
different orientations which I evaluated
for every single drug and this process
happens for hundreds of millions of drug
like compounds so you might be wondering
why is this important
so by this process we can find most
promising drug like candidates and then
we can select them and test them
actually in the lab and here the story
gets even more interesting in the past
two years the size of these small drug
like molecules libraries have grown
rapidly what used to be in tens of
millions a few years ago is now have
grown to more than a billion in size so
while this presents a great challenge in
terms of size of the problem and
compatibility this presents a unique
opportunity in terms of exploring the
ever expanding chemical space to have
more options to find better drugs like
chemicals from so in a nutshell what's
work for us is the speed at which we can
do computations on the cloud so let me
do a simple comparison what we have in
our lab is on the Left it's usually
founded processors and what we have on
the cloud
so you are using almost 200,000
processing processors in parallel at a
given point in time and what used to
take more than a year to screen at such
a scale now takes less than a day or two
on the cloud so far in this story which
began almost a year ago with the help of
National Institute of Health and its
program pilot its pilot program on cloud
computing and also with the help from
NIDA and an issue of drug abuse and
Google research pilot programs the
screen almost half a billion of such
drug like compounds and we selected 120
compounds and tested them in the lab and
indeed we found some of the promising
compounds which have shown desired
signaling profiles so we'll continue our
fight against the opioid epidemic in the
cloud in the hope of saving millions of
lives and changing the faces of the
addiction with that I'd like to thank
you all and special thanks to my mental
process a lot ca'tridge and solution
added from Google and Jim from onyx
tomorrow Nolan and I thought it was
fantastic that you're able to get get
going with a prototype in one day at a
campus hackathon what would advice be
what would the advice be that you would
give to other students that are looking
to get started on GCP so I think when I
got started with GCP I didn't have much
programming experience
I took few classes but not more than
that and what I would say is just go and
try stuff I failed my first hackathon
and we won the second one and I think
every one we went to since then so just
keep trying do crazy stuff do easy stuff
then go to stuff that are harder and and
keep trying the GCP console makes it
really easy to achieve great stuff
I mean I think Tama covered most of it
like he said biggie from easy things
like Google Translate API is very simple
to use and you can have a result in a
minute and it's very satisfying so maybe
try that
[Music]